[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle saison de
paf qui reprend premier numéro de
septembre et on vous remercie d'ailleurs
de votre fidélité puisque j'ai appris
que paf a été l'émission la plus
podcastée pendant l'été on a beaucoup de
sujets à aborder notamment notamment un
événement qui est à la fois locales
régionales nationales et mondiales qui
est celui de la ryder cup et on va
parler aussi de beaucoup d'autres sujets
notamment du remaniement notamment des
assises du medef
beaucoup de sujets abordés mais on va
parler aussi de la ryder cup et pour en
parler je suis ravi de l'accueil à
arnaud courtier vous êtes le directeur
de cabinet du président de saint quentin
en yvelines jean michel fourgous
mais vous êtes aussi vous avez aussi un
passé très sportif vous avez été à la
fédération française de golf vous avez
été directeur général de la fédération
française de cyclisme dont clément et
vous allez nous dire peut-être au fond
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour
peut-être pour les habitants de ce
territoire pendant la ryder cup
laurent mazaury bonjour président
monsieur le président si vous êtes le
président 2 tv soixante dix huit vous
êtes élu des locaux vous êtes vice
président de la cud et et saint quentin
en yvelines et président donc de cette
division et vous aussi vous avez déjà
assisté ou participé à la candidature de
50 ha pour la pour la ryder cup vous
nous raconterez un peu tout ça quelle
est l'importance ou font de cet
événement
florence par cas des souks et bonjour
vous êtes à votre caste au barreau de
versailles et vous avez ainsi ce pas bon
et pas golfeuses et pas deux golfeuses
ou non voilà ça ne vous intéresse
absolument pas vous ne verrez pas faire
comme je dirais quoi
non mais vous étiez en revanche aux
acides du medef absolument urgent aux as
et jean charles lajoie dit bonjour je
vous retrouvez vous êtes éditeur les
aides existent vous êtes président des
éditions la troupe absolument absolument
et vous publiez alors je n'ai pas lu
métrage in assez de sept derniers le
dernier volume de votre absolument c'est
notre vision des relations et sandrine
bezard ni soumis à deux voilà c'est un
roman à quatre mains c'est entre le
polar bleus l'espionnage le losc reader
et des traces et le et le jazz et le
jazz faux cap aller vite parce qu'il ya
notamment eu une scène assez assez sympa
dans un caveau à paris non mais c'est
très évident on voyage on va même à
dakar parce que la boue pharmaceutique
en gym à mithra gina c'est le nom d'une
plante qui existe qui est sur la
couverture et qu'il aime de possibilités
et de la très gentille de potentiel si
si si au contraire non c'est vraiment
une plante justement et où tout le monde
se bat pour l'avoir écarté des les
bienfaits notamment certains labos met
donc à consommer légalement ça voilà à
consommer tout à fait légalement
après quelques petites préparations
quand même dans un labo voilà c'est bon
ça alors la rai dark dark dark à paris
ça sera du 25 au 30 septembre
c'est donc dans quelques dans quelques
semaines quoi alors d'abord peut-être
revenons quand même la victoire de de
paris de versailles de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de la france
donc c'est pas elle s'est pas donnée
parce que on a l'impression que c'est
pas encore pour les français un
événement majeur si vous aimez ça
devrait l'être alors c'est un vrai sujet
ça devrait l'être d'abord parce que
c'est un le troisième événement le plus
médiatisé au monde a cédé année des
années de combat pour obtenir cet
événement saint quentin en yvelines
je vais mettre c'est quand on devine
devrait parce que oui majeurs américains
mettront par elle et moi je n'ai jamais
à clermont dire on bat paris mais aurait
il été 0 à saint girons saint quentin en
yvelines
voilà ça a été un vrai combat un combat
qui a traversé quasiment dix ans de
travail à saint quentin par les épis qui
nous ont précédés et nous aujourd'hui un
combat de haute lutte face à aux autres
pays européens qui voulait avoir cette
ryder cup parce qu'au delà de l'image de
bain à tout le monde se bat puisque
c'est énormément de participation enfin
à nous nous en parlera dans un instant
et puis parce que c'est l'emblème de la
france puis c'est l'emblème d'un golf
que l'on veut aussi démocratisée et puis
c'est beaucoup de visibilité pour le
pays hôte
beaucoup de visiter pour territoire qui
reçoit beaucoup de visibilité pour un
sport qui reste encore malheureusement
trop confidentielle avons les pays qui
nous entourent c'est quasiment sport
démocratique
troisième événement le plus télévision
au monde donc ça veut dire quelque chose
voilà c'est très populaire c'est plus
d'un milliard et demi de téléspectateurs
qui ont les yeux braqués sur saint
quentin en yvelines pendant quasiment
quatre jours c'est évidemment mettre en
avant un territoire sportif dynamique
afin c'est toute l'image d'un sport que
le golf est un sport nature 1 par
essence cabot d'ailleurs fait des
révolutions absolument extraordinaire
sur l'entretien la maintenance et
parcours qui a été longtemps décrié qui
aujourd'hui à mon avis aussi bien en
consommation d'eau qu'en traitement des
eaux et c'est le même que ce que nos
amis footeux peuvent avoir donc voilà
c'est ce combat là il a été mené pendant
plus de dix ans pour obtenir cette
qualification est ensuite le fait d'être
tenues pays hôte et dans la foulée la
préparation de 2024 nous serons aussi
été rejetée à la pique et le golf se
rabaisser selick
il faut dire c'est presque aussi
importants que les jeux olympiques enfin
ça c'est un événement majeur quoi enfin
sportivement et c'est aussi un truc bien
pousser dont il connaît mon jeu sur un
seul endroit pendant quatre jours alors
que par essence
les jeux olympiques sont certes la télé
sont éclatés et donc du coup le le taux
de concentration de visibilité plus
importante sur un seul sport a en a
seulement il n'y a pas d'équivalent
j'allais dire qu'alors la coupe du monde
de football va dire c'est à dire devant
mais là aussi la coupe de monde de
football on l'a vu en russie les érudits
au mieux ses cadres et non surtout aline
est un pays où il faut prendre l'avion
là ici vous avez qu à prendre de but
c'est quand même
beaucoup plus écologique et beaucoup
plus rapide et efficace par deux
courtiers c'est évidemment un enjeu
annonce très fort pour pour la pour 50
ans joue très fort je voudrais rajouter
aux propos de laurent que effectivement
le golf n'est pas encore culturelle dans
notre pays fait pas partie de notre
histoire il faudra du temps mais le
deviendra mais pour qu'on comprenne
l'importance de cet événement au niveau
planétaire il faut il ya un élément à
connaître le golf et le sport individuel
le plus pratiqué dans le monde
une fois qu'on sait sahraoui on comprend
pourquoi savoir événements ont parlé
devant tous les autres sports c'est le
sport individuel le plus pratiqué dans
le monde depuis longtemps donc voilà je
fumais en jour la plante y avait à boire
au moins sale à dire si on regarde si on
regarde les grands champions c'est vrai
que dans le passé il ya mais voilà
exactement aujourd'hui c'est quand même
des athlètes
ce sont exactement ce sont des athlètes
champions cédant aux golfeurs on est au
niveau peut-être au plus haut niveau et
du rap français quoi on conduira pas
compensé en partie n'y en a pas deux
qualifiés voilà c'est comme ça juste on
a déjà eu des français en ryder cup
c'est ballot on espère conduire les deux
exactement il y en a même eu 3 3
puisqu'une jean van de velde thomas
levet et victor dubuisson et auteur de
mission va le manger donc donc événement
extraordinaire pour saint-quentin en
yvelines parce que ça va me permettre de
mettre notre territoire sous les feux de
la rampe pendant une semaine pour le
monde entier comme comme les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste l'avait fait mais là on est dans
une ampleur véritablement planétaire
puisque ce mal qui est un match etats
unis europe quand même deux puissances
économiques qui vont s'affronter là sur
le parcours de golf mais la ryder cup
est très très populaire aussi en asie
par exemple ça fonctionne très bien on
regarde tous les mois c'est vraiment
tout le mal est donc c'est important on
va recevoir beaucoup de public on va
avoir
certainement on sait qu'on va
certainement battre des records
d'affluence donc sur la totalité on
devrait dépasser les 300 mille
spectateurs
par jour une capacité d'un peu plus de
60000 spectateurs par jour
il faut savoir que si on en est là
aujourd'hui c'est aussi parce que à la
fin des années 80 des gens qui avaient
une vision à l'époque président de la
fédération française de golf claude
roger quartier oui et les saint quentin
en yvelines ont voulu construire un
stade de golf et à l'époque oui c'est
qu'il avait déjà cette idée un dernier
paraissait fou à l'époque il avait deux
ans ville avait deux rêves qui était un
jour accueillir la ryder cup en france
c'était toute la librairie vizada
surtout en france à l'époque octobre les
quartiers milité pour le retour du golf
aux jeux olympiques va accueillir la
ryder et les jeux donc voilà c'est
extraordinaire et ce parcours a été
construit pour ça c'est le seul parcours
aujourd'hui qui est cette disposition de
stadium de golf avec des buts qui
permettent de voir le jeu de haut
donc les spectateurs vont se régaler ils
vont avoir d une vue parfaite sur le
parcours on va accueillir des gens qui
viennent du monde entier même si aura
beaucoup de français a beaucoup de
français ont acheté des billets mais au
moins beaucoup de gens vont avoir
l'opportunité de découvrir saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est un point important ce point du
stadium de gauche parce que moi j'ai eu
le plaisir d'aller à gleneagles par
exemple pour préparer et le problème
majeur d'une ryder cup en général c'est
que l'engouement est tel est la quantité
de spectateurs et elle sait qu'on a en
général 10 à 15 rangs de gens de bon
debout devant vous et qu'on ne voit rien
et que souvent on entend plus qu'on ne
voit là saint quentin avec cette
construction là je pense que 100 % des
spectateurs auront l'occasion de voir
les coups de golf et on vient quand même
pour ça et ça c'est tout à fait
particulier et avait des kills l'anis et
c'est une bonne question parce que on se
dit quand on voit comme ça le canton va
sur le golf est ce qu'on va voir quelque
chose si on y va dès lors vous a vu à la
télé mais à la télé il ya pas l'ambiance
il ya pas là il n'ya pas le taux des
sports on voit parfaitement à la télé il
ya pas de byte mais là il ya l'envié
c'est une ambiance de stade de foot sur
un terrain de golf c'est assez
particulier
oui parce que spectateur police a pris à
sa sortie ça y va en plus des joueurs
aujourd'hui moderne il ya le faire le
faire que l'habituel du golfe et
d'étiquettes mais des joueurs veulent du
bruit aujourd'hui voilà il aime que ça
fasse du bruit même quand ils jouent ils
sont habitués à ça et les matches et en
condensé dure quelques trous ça c'est
pas sur tout le parcours comme un
tournoi de golf habituel le public suit
les matches et donc on voit vraiment le
jeu et à saint quentin en yvelines le
parcours est fait pour qu'on en profite
pleinement et tout le monde va en
profiter pleinement
l'enjeu pour le pour le pour 50 à celles
qua non pour saint quentin c'est un
concours serait pas alors c'est un ange
notoriété est un enjeu de développement
économique pour être très clair l'action
que saint quentin en yvelines mène
pendant cette ryder cup au niveau de
l'événement et de la loge que saint
quentin en yvelines aura sur l'événement
c'est l'accueil de chefs d'entreprise
étrangers principalement avec des
projets d'implantation de siège en
france et si possible en ile de france
et encore mieux à saint quentin en
yvelines que nous recevons pour leur
faire découvrir notre territoire et pour
leur montrer justement le dynamisme de
ce territoire qu'un écart de performance
économique numérique sociale etc sportif
bien sûr et les convaincre de venir
travailler avec nous et de travailler
ici donc c'est un ordre économique
oui bien sûr c'est pendant une semaine
saint quentin en yvelines va être saoul
et sous les caméras le monde qui va nous
voir des spectateurs qui sont pas
forcément particulièrement intéressé par
saint-quentin mais des chefs
d'entreprise des gens qui peut-être vont
venir travailler dans cette région des
gens qui cherchent un endroit où vivre
heureux on a la chance d'avoir un
territoire magnifique avec beaucoup
d'activités dont le sport qui fait
partie de l'adn du territoire puisque on
sera quatre fois sites olympiques en
2024 avec le cyclisme sur piste le bmx
le vtt et le golf
donc on a beaucoup de choses à offrir le
florence remarquable et c'est par votre
passion mais si je vous dit tiger woods
par exemple ça vous dit quelque chose
qui sera là
ça vous a été confirmée il sera là il
sera là joueurs en plus il sera pas
uniquement vi qu'allah joueurs là ça
veut dire que j'ai dire il y avoir des
émeutes
non ça veut dire qu'on fait pour la
sécurité qui s'occupent de ça c'est
l'organisation de la ryder tout un
travail est fait et est menée depuis
plusieurs années maintenant avec
l'organisation de la ryder cup ryder cup
europe
la fédération française de golf saint
quentin en yvelines et les autorités
bien sûr la préfecture
c'est la même chose pour tout ce qui est
plan de transport tous les aménagements
nécessaires à cet événement
effectivement quand on accueille
soixante mille spectateurs par jour ça
ne s'improvise pas au dernier moment il
ya plus de 7000 personnes par jour je
crois au niveau des hospitalités donc
voilà il ya beaucoup beaucoup de monde
plus de 2000 journalistes présents ce
qui montre un petit peu l'ampleur des
événements aussi donc c'est un travail
qui est mené depuis plusieurs années
maintenant pour que le jour j au
démarrage de l'événement tout soit
parfaitement en place et fonctionne le
dans la plus grande fluidité possible
aussi je vous propose de voir un sujet
justement sur les travaux qui se sont
faits actuellement au golf national 22
mètres de haut si 1800 places assises
avec cette super tribune la ryder cup
2018 est déjà inscrite dans l'histoire
de la compétition avant même d'avoir
commencé sa capacité cinq fois
supérieure à celle de la dernière
édition organisée en 2016 aux états unis
et joueurs amateurs du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines n'en
reviennent pas à les impressionnantes
allait elle est belle elle est grande
pour le départ du 1 c'est parfait elle
est immense
j'ai entendu dire qu'elle faisait 6000
places je suis impressionné la tribune
éphémère encore en cours de construction
permettrait d'avoir une vision sur 11
des 18 trous du parcours
les spectateurs pourront notamment voir
le premier coup de la compétition le
vendredi 28 septembre l'ambiance autre
numéro 1 est devenu quelque chose dans
l'héritage de la ryder cup c'est
mythique l'ambiance quand tu les veux
rentrer dans l'arène et ce bruit
assourdissant donc je pense qu'on a
voulu l'amplifier encore plus parce que
non seulement il y aura les 6800
personnes à 6 mais il y aura aussi la
même voire dix mille personnes 2
pour avoir sa place dans cette tribune
les spectateurs devront faire sonner le
réveil entre 5 heures et 6 heures du
matin objectif être les premiers à
accéder au site
il ya des placements dans la tribune un
peu derrière un peu plus bas à peu près
du départ du 1 qui qu'on pouvait au gré
des notes billets pour préserver la
place mais sur les 6800 place il ya
simplement 1000 places qui ont été
préservés grâce à 1800 c'est pour toute
personne qui est sur le site bien
habillés ils ont accès ici à la tribune
en parallèle de cette superstructure le
golf a vu se dresser des pavillons et
des tribunes pouvant accueillir des
milliers de spectateurs sur le parcours
l'ensemble sera livré au plus tard le 19
septembre avant le passage des
différentes commissions de sécurité
voilà on a volé les tribunes par les
stades c'est encore plus au stade
lorsqu'on évoquait les records
d'affluence qu'on va battre donc là il
va y avoir une ambiance extraordinaire
et une tribune de 6000 spectateurs ça
s'est jamais fait sur une ryder cup il
faut savoir que les les fans les
premiers sont là l'ouverture à 5h30 du
matin en train d'attendre et au ca ou
vous pourrez la retraite aurait sur dans
la tribune on aura certainement la
présence des fameux guardian of the code
qui est un groupe de britanniques avec
des tenues qu'on repère de loin qui
chante des chansons qui ont cours à
l'europe
il se passe quelque chose et quand vous
avez 60 mille spectateurs qui crient
tous ensemble you drop europe je peux
vous assurer qu'il se passe quelque
chose et que vrai qu'il ya quelques
regrets
là c'est mort evènement avant les mêmes
alors on est en ligne avec philippe
pilate hockey le directeur adjoint du
golf national bonjour philippe bonjour
alors justement on vient de voir un
sujet là sur les travaux et les
magnifiques tribune là qu'ils sont en
train de qui sont construites au globe
nationale qu'est ce qui va se passer
autre aujourd'hui au de maintenant et
puis le 25 septembre des moulins yzeure
cup sur le golf national ya encore pas
mal de travaux à faire un an que j'ai
une commission de sécurité qui est
prévue le 20 banques
donc voilà pourquoi après effectivement
alors qu'il ya effectivement encore
beaucoup de travaux à mettre en place
d'ici là avec notamment de la
finalisation vous entendez parler de la
tribu du trou numéro 1 réalisation la
tribune sylvain et qui va couvrir tout
l'arrière dû produire au xviii il
permettra donc aux spectateurs de voir
le 18 et le 15
on a les écrans géants parce que sur si
tu vas y avoir 80 écrans géants
donc il faut finaliser ces écrans géants
et à l'habillage également des oeuvres
de vider voir votre abdomen avec tout le
petit blanc 10,1 et tous les bâtiments
propre golf la boutique des bureaux de
patience que l'équipe européenne puisse
investir les dieux et habillés aux
couleurs couleurs de vie beaucoup
beaucoup de travail
et alors il ya évidemment tous tous qui
accueille les spectateurs il ya aussi le
le parcours et on le brûle travail
jusqu'au dernier moment
mallat a marre qui lui fait dans le
parcours
oui actuellement les intermédiaires soit
verdi exactement est donc là maintenant
on met le parcours un petit peu oui
là il est tout à fait certes il imite un
petit peu les ailes et les actions de
tonte et ainsi de suite de façon à à le
faire se reposer parce que effectivement
sûr on va dire à partir de
une quinzaine de jours avant les
instants donc il va y avoir de grosses
opérations notamment de tonte et ainsi
de suite qu'ils vont quand même pas mal
stressé le parcours et le façon à ce que
le parcours absorbe de bonnes passes ont
ré toutes les opérations qui auront lieu
sur les quinze derniers jours et
notamment l'aspect du tournoi avec
certains vendaient des donc matin le
soir
donc là il le laisse aux us un petit pas
en repos il finalise certainement
actuellement tout ce qui est zones
extérieures où je d'agrifrance que le
parcours bon ben on voit que voilà paul
dynamitage vous philippe pilate et de
nos équipes vous avez du boulot jusqu'au
bout jusqu'au 25
donc on va vous laisser très belle même
si le golf national et est fermé
jusqu'au début de la ryder cup est
fermée au public bat donc qu'on vous
souhaite bon courage et puis voilà
comment de commencer que vous avez
beaucoup beaucoup et très bien travaillé
on vous félicite déjà merci philippe un
mot quand même alors 20 pour arnaud sur
les journées le public
alors parce que les gens se disent moi
j'habite à côté du golf national donc je
vais y aller avec ma bagnole ou je vais
y aller avec mon vélo je voyais c'est
pas possible
non c'est pas possible effectivement il
ya un plan de transport et on l'a dit
60000 spectateurs par jour ça fait
beaucoup de monde il faut que tout soit
parfaitement organisée donc j'invite
d'ailleurs tous le monde à lire le
dernier ce qui marque dans lequel on
trouve toutes les informations sur la
ryder cup sur ce qui s'y passait sur le
plan de transport pour venir à cette
ryder on pourra pas venir à pied on
pourra pas venir en vélo ni en
trottinette ni en planche à roulettes
ils vont en voiture il faut prendre les
circuits d'accès les navettes
effectivement il y aura de chaque côté
du golf national à l'est et à l'ouest de
hub d'accès ou arriveront tout et
navettes qui seront en provenance des
parkings officiels et des gares donc
pour les saint quentinois et ceux qui
habitent à saint quentin le plus simple
est encore de se rendre à la gare de 50
ans david vraiment il y aura des
navettes et développe aux gars et il ya
les parkings autour donc on
on peut se garer dans les parkings et
puis sinon il ya le réseau de bus tout
fonctionne tout à fait normalement et
dès qu'ils ont un billet d'accès à la
ryder cup grâce à ce billet peuvent
entrer dans la gare des navettes ryder
cup et sur iphone oui il faut le billet
gratuite mais il faut le billet là aussi
question de sécurité bien sûr ne peuvent
accéder à l'événement que les gens qui
sont munis d'un billet est bon donc vous
vous êtes prêts quoi avait plutôt pas
mal jusqu'au dernier moment on va tout
vérifier et revérifier il ya des
aménagements spécifiques effectivement
parce que ça fait beaucoup de navettes
supplémentaires une gare n'a de navettes
qui est construite et de manière
éphémère à la gare de saint quentin
parce qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de
spectateurs qui vont arriver parce par
ce biais par le train par le rer
mais oui on est prêts absolument on va
peut-être montré le chemin de fer le
magazine et puis non aulas sur le site
aussi de te voilà avec des avec des
saint quentinois en couverture parce que
les gens soient là c'est quand même il y
aura beaucoup de bénévoles sur cet
espace il y aura mille deux cents
bénévoles qui participent à la ryder cup
et beaucoup de saint quentinois qui ceux
qui se sont impliqués et qui ont été
sélectionnés et qui vont être
commissaire de parcours qui vont aider à
oublier qu'ils vont faire beaucoup de
choses et qui vont être présents sur
l'événement c'est une autre manière de
vivre l'événement qui est assez
intéressante en étant bénévole et je
signale que c'est david ginola qui
animera la cérémonie d'ouverture
et puis la cérémonie de remise des qui
ont fait un très bel faire deux très
bons golfeurs qui connaît bien
l'angleterre puisque ring et puis et
puis c'est qu'ils parlent aussi très
bien anglais qui parle très bien anglais
qui a accompagné la candidature de la
france puisqu'en 2011 quand la la france
était candidate il était royaume uni
avec nous aussi au caltech manner pour
la ryder cup pour promouvoir la france
pour l'obtention de cette ryder cup donc
là donc c'est très bien que ce soit lui
et puis c'est un type charmant jugé pour
des violences dont les beaux mecs je
sais plus
d'avoir un oeil très inquiet sur la
météo oui oui oui c'est plus sympa s'il
fait beau après la pluie fait partie du
jeu va partir du jeu fait partie du jeu
il ya eu d'énormes travaux faits au golf
national depuis l'attribution de la
ryder cup pour ne plus revivre justement
ce qui s'était passé au pays de galles
aucun petit manoir où il y avait eu un
jour de décalage tellement il y avait eu
de pluie sur ce golf qui était une
sévère mais pour les arrivées c'est
terrible mais par contre les travaux qui
ont été faits au golf national font que
même s'il pleut énormément oui c'est
pour ça qu'il irait droit il et il est
très bien drainés satis et moins
sympathique cible pour les domaines mais
ça fait partie du jeu au golf et vous
avez une petite idée vous suivez
régulièrement la méthode et les alertes
oui bien sûr non mais bien sûr ça tout
est surveillée comme pendant tous les
concernant serti dans vingt jours si
c'était des précisions c'est un peu tôt
avec huit jours avant le 22 septembre à
l'open tv 78 cadieux aussi à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines j'espère que
huit jours avant les travaux s'il fait
beau on vous enverra un petit peu de
beau temps pour la ryder cabinet
partenaire mais c'est une excellente
moi j'adore le gaz au golf blue green
ligue de l'ouest 51 50 ha et on peut
voir la fiche on peut encore s'inscrire
à oui oui tout à fait vous pouvez
scanner le petit flash code qui apparaît
à l'écran dont vous pouvez effectivement
ils rendent sur les sites de bluegreen
de saint-quentin de télé sont dits pour
vous inscrire c'est la troisième édition
n'ont pas je voulais faire la retape
comme on dit pour l'événement mais il se
trouve que chaque fois que nous avons
fait cet événement là je sais pas si les
batteries vous avez vous en souvenez
mais nous avions toujours de l'appui à
vent de la pluie après le genre
d'événement les choses est bon les
arrières et admirable voilà et donc je
souhaite qu'il se passe la même chose
mais je suis certain qu'une semaine
après on aura beau temps à 50 d'abord
que c'est toujours beau à 50 ans
visiblement ça fait partie du territoire
d'innovation mais on verra notre secret
pour ça que ça a été choisi on trouve ça
d'abord la historiquement la station
météo la plus importante de france au
début de recherche et et attrapes et
donc du coup on bénéficie de cette
espèce de parapluies de météo pour
pratiquer le sport pour tous les saint
quentinois que
le golf blue green day et de loisirs est
aussi un endroit idéal pour découvrir le
golf si on n'a jamais su allier il ya
beaucoup de bonnes choses
c'est un peu le couvert il ya plein d
initiation gratuite c'est vraiment un
endroit idéal pour découvrir le parcours
et demi si je peux le dire il y avait
quelque chose de l'installation
c'est un très bel endroit gens ça remet
ça au pythie ou ça vous ça me passionne
pour l'instant parce que on est enfin
encore un petit peu loin du de la montée
de l'excitation du démarrage cours
les équipes se valent c'est un peu
décevant si ya pas de française parce
que comme dans toute compétition c'est
tout le monde aura j'espère qu'allah
vous censé et lévis était pas très loin
il se trouve que moi s'enthousiasme
désormais de plus dans une compétition
quand il avait on voit bien même les
scores des dents les derniers tournois
de tennis n'y a pas de français je vis
en semaine on est là il apprend les
intérêts n'a pas non plus donc ça c'est
un peu dommage après c'est vrai que le
golf c'est un sport magnifique c'est
bien c'est je vois ça d'un très bon oeil
après voilà j'espère que l'europe se
montrera à la hauteur
ça va pas être facile et un petit
désavantage les états unis où un
président golfeurs à l'est alors que
notre avantage s'il était excellent
golfeur je pense qu'on serait les
golfeurs ils mènent volontairement
bouton d'alerté remarqué mais l'été
c'est très méchant il était hyper disant
qu'ils étaient interdits de
d'enterrement donc voilà
c'est ma canne alors que dans ces
dispositions testamentaires à goderich
je veux pas que mon enterrement
c'est vrai que ce n'était pas les
meilleurs amis du monde comme vous par
crochet on peut pas reprocher ni les
golfeurs mais le golf est d'abord
culturel dans tats unis et voilée faire
comme les obama comme les clients des
poules bourdonner sont tous golfeurs
oui et alors il ya un bruit même qui dit
qu'il serait bien dray pour la ryder cup
difficile aussi bien géré ce qu'on
l'apprendra le jour même mais je pense
mais c'est pas possible j'ai pas sûr
qu'il est prévu de me téléphoner pour
venir enfin bon c'est pas ça serait pas
si non c'est pas vrai en europe dans
c'est lui ou à ses prédécesseurs aussi
d'ailleurs
ce qu'on peut dire section suis sur
twitter le président europe je sais
qu'il a reçues compris des invitations
de saint quentinois qui ont été jusqu'au
bout et qui ont dit mais monsieur le
président vous venez donc nous voir on
va peut-être vous avec lui oui on n'a
pas eu trop occupé je pense qu'on
évitera comme il ya des son but je crois
pour les présidents la visualisant
parcours le président français est
attendu
oui le président et le premier ministre
la patrouille de france 25 à 30 la vraie
corvée 10 ans et 29 ans la compétition
et vendredi samedi dimanche mais toute
la semaine et des animations il ya les
journées où il ya l'entraînement
d'ezéchiel hausse très sympa parce que
je vois il s'entraîne on les voit ils
sont décontractés ils sont pas encore
dans la pression de la compétition
tandis voilà à peine kombouaré mais si
on va les voir si on les voit relégué
une proximité qui est la même que celle
que nous aurions dû sa salade on les
voit de près donc c'est vraiment
impressionnant et comme dans tous les
sports
quand on les voit jouer de prêts ou
voilà la réalité du mouvement du swing
en l'occurrence mais c'est comme un
match de tennis qu'on est au bord du
terrain par rapport à conduire son écran
de télé le ressenti n'est pas du tout le
même
vous étiez on va parler peut-être du
medef c'était 40 ans du medef nom de 20
ans c'était le cnpf vois pas ce que je
vais faire du medef c'était une
organisation qui existait déjà
auparavant c'était donc à jouy en josas
chaque année fin août on a vu naître
patron un peu râleur je trouve déçu que
oui j'ai trouvé que l'ambiance était un
peu molle par rapport à 2010 est où là
il y avait c'était très enthousiaste là
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait un petit peu
moins de nom c'était un peu moins
intéressant que les années d'avant et
les patrons rencontre était un peu sur
la réserve
oui ça préserve pas peut-être enfin ces
petits qu'ils attendent de voir oui
c'est ça on va on va regarder c'est
justement sur les vingt ans pas de
nostalgie pour son anniversaire pour ses
20 ans le medef regarde vers l'avenir et
pense à l'entreprise dans deux décennies
l'entreprise que nous sommes aujourd'hui
c'est décidé il ya 50 ans et on
travaille à stabiliser à pérenniser
l'entreprise pour les 50 prochaines
années chez sodexo pour nous
l'entreprise si vous voulez c'est une
communauté c'est une communauté d
intérêts de ses actionnaires de ses
salariés de ses fournisseurs et de ses
clients
allez donc tout est décliné avec en
faisant en réalisant cette synthèse une
réflexion tournée vers le futur choisi
par le nouveau président du mouvement
élu en juillet dernier les entreprises
tournées vers l'europe les nouvelles
technologies l'intelligence artificielle
c'est un ménage de propositions à ménez
qui va qui va regarder les autres qui va
proposer et qui va être dans la
concertation
on est aujourd'hui dans une économie de
confiance de confiance confiance avec
nos partenaires confiance avec les
politiques confiance avec les salariés
confiance et ça se bâtit on est dans un
monde qui bouge énormément et je pense
que le grand groupe en lui même les
grands groupes tels qu'on les a connus
notamment en france vont être amenés à
bouger
ils vont peut-être changer énormément de
l'intérieur les start up sont en train
de grossir aussi donc elles vont aussi
venir sa ligne et plus de 4500
entrepreneurs ont répondu présent cette
année les syndicats ont profité de
l'événement pour se rassembler près de
200 d'entre eux ont tracté durant la
matinée du 29 août à l'entrée du campus
on a des propositions sur le statut de
l'encadrement le droit à la déconnexion
l'équilibré vie privée-vie
professionnelle l'égalité femmes-hommes
aussi qui est très
une revendication très importante voilà
et puis à montrer une présence montre et
voilà qu'à d'autres d'autre choix
possible que ce que cherche à imposer le
medef pour la rentrée une intersyndicale
appelle déjà la mobilisation le 9
octobre pour protester contre la
politique sociale du gouvernement
donc voilà mais les patrons qui étaient
réunis à jouy en josas alors quelques
inquiétudes sur le plan économique il ya
aussi peut-être à cette information que
le premier ministre a confirmé au
journal de 20 heures c'est à dire le
prélèvement à la source qui va mettre
évidemment les entreprises à
contribution largement à contribution
c'est à dire qu'il faut c'est d'ailleurs
un problème de peut-être de secret pour
les posies pour les salariés alors il ya
plusieurs problèmes qui se posent il ya
un problème technique c'est à dire qu'il
va falloir remettre des logiciels
différents faire changer de logiciel
pour sortir des bulletins de salaire
puisque la va falloir intégrer cette
donnée de de prélèvement à la source va
falloir ensuite faire le télépaiement
c'est au niveau des entreprises c'est
quelque chose de louche de déjeuner avec
une drh d'une entreprise coûte une
grosse entreprise de 800 salariés qui me
disait faut en gros en termes techniques
en investissement ses 15000 euros déjà
donc oui c'est oui parce qu'il faut
avoir le logiciel qui va bien et il faut
tout changer
donc pour une petite entreprise si elle
a un logiciel la focale le change c'est
le chant d'un terne et je ne doute pas
que les experts comptables qui eux vont
devoir sortir des bulletins de salaire
comme on externalise la paye vont
augmenter le prix du bulletin de salaire
etc les entreprises directement qui vont
subir ces augmentations
alors ça c'est le premier volet qui est
un volet purement économique mais qui
n'est pas rien et le deuxième volet
c'est ce que craignent les entreprises
et ce qui se disait justement aux
universités d'été du medef
c'est la crainte d'avoir
au 1er février quand les salariés ont
leur bulletin de salaire du mois de
janvier des gens dans le bureau en
disant mais c'est quoi cette paye je
gagne moins et puis robert qu'elle-même
brut que moi il a pas de l'aisne salaire
net et finalement ça va revenir aux
entreprises de faire les explications de
faire les expliquer alors ils français
sont pas complètement stupide ils savent
bien que ils vont avoir internet
inférieur et en termes de trésorerie
s'ils sont mutualisés bon certains mais
psychologiquement c'est important parce
qu'en terme de trésorerie ça change ça
changera rien je ne pense pas que les
gaulois passent leur temps s'échanger
leur fils leur fiche de 10 salariés
comparent le net me compare pas le brut
sans vous aimez gagner la même chose que
le collègue
et que fait que sur le vous avez sur le
beaucoup moins renommés vous qu'ils vont
comprendre si ce n'est que les drh vont
une fois de drh ou de chefs
d'entreprises petites entreprises vont
être mis à contribution pour essayer de
dégonfler ces problèmes-là et de dons
qu'il ya à la fois un problème
psychologique et alors il ya un autre
problème mais das a manifestement été
résolus c'était le problème du débit de
crédit d'impôt donc là apparemment c
mais après
voilà il ya des situations différentes
et justement puisque vous parlez aspect
psychologique qu'est ce que ça peut
avoir un impact sur la consommation
c'est à dire que on se dit ok - donc je
dépense moins ce que logiquement je
pense que c'est le premier point
j'aurais mis en examen je suis d'accord
sur des preuves et des entreprises
absolue de l'avantagé d'un homme
politique qui aurait été un vrai métier
voilà je dirais donc société c'est la
même problématique
on a dix ans pour toi je pense à des
petites agences de voyages qui ont un
salarié c'est un cauchemar et l'impact
effectivement sur l'entreprise à la
finale on objets de leur basculer sur
qui sur les clients et donc quelque part
on participe
voilà à l'eau des puits ce qui va bien
avec mais oui c'est un effet
psychologique évident c'est le premier
point
si on peut dire ce que l'on veut mais
quand on est d'abord si on n'était pas
mensualisé ça pose une problématique
puisque on va se retrouver effectivement
mensualisés donc avoir moins tous les
mois
tout de suite aujourd'hui ils viennent
pas me raconter comme je le premier
ministre y asseoir que ça va mieux parce
que vas tu as quelqu'un jours d'accord
ça n'a pas de sens tout cas côté démence
n'a pas de sens et quand effectivement
vous gagnez 1800 euros il demain vous
avez 1600 bas pour vous est de 100 euros
de moins et c'est pas la même chose
entre elles n'ont plus de flux sur le
compte bancaire puisque évidemment votre
banque
elle peu lui importe de savoir d'où
vient l'argent ce qui compte c'est ce
qui est donc vous aurez effectivement un
volume bancaire sur votre compte qui
sera moins important que vous avez avec
4 dont il ya évidemment la fête
écologique même si vous avez raison le
blue avait pas forcément réel c'est
intelligent même si ça revient aux
mamans en gros bouées et d'ailleurs des
amortis puisqu'on parle de montée pour
bien connue des cerfs des sportifs se
négocie sur des pièces que je ne négocie
pas sur le brut
même sur des consoles est là en terme de
pouvoir d'achat juste aussi pour
rebondir sur ce que vous dites c'est que
là aujourd'hui un commercial va voir
jusqu'à la fin de l'année s'il est
mensualisé sur dix mois toujours la même
somme qui va être déduite
sauf qu'à partir du mois de janvier il
ya un mois où il a des commissions où il
aura moi il ya un mois où il a pas de
commission mais il aura autre chose et
instituts donc il a alors la vénération
qui va être très variable est ce que
c'est ça justement parce que par exemple
que vous recevez votre avis d'impôt
cette année on vous donne tout
vincent si on vous donne le tout c'est
quand même pour quelque chose s'est
passé pour l'appliquer ces graffitis sur
le bulletin
donc quand on dit mais oui mais si vous
gagnez moins en février mais on va je
vous appliquer le même taux quand même à
bien sûr donc donc il ya un truc qui me
qui marchent pas bon mais alors après
faut aller pour régulariser les premiers
prix je suis pas certain qu'il y aura
moins de ça va supprimer beaucoup de
postes à bercy parce que la faim et des
tas de gens qui m'ont téléphoné en
disant attention danger gagner moi qui
fusaient de tous était calculée sur le
salaire de l'année 2007 d'accord donc
l'escaut bien sûr de vous parler ses
cannes on a 150 sur un effectif de 1000
les commerciaux qui dans l'année 2016
ont par chance de gagner effectivement
plus que l'année 2019 ont éclaté grand
fair en 2016
enfin il ya on voit bien que ce système
ne fonctionne pas enfin pour moi ne
fonctionne pas mais moi je suis
farouchement opposé de pardon je pense
qu'il ya une solution
c'était lamentable nature dis-moi
d'heure sur 12
oui ce qui fait que vous générez ou même
un effet positif parce que là pour le
coup les faits d'avoir sur 10 et sur 12
vous récupériez en apparence plus de
pouvoir d'achat
j'avais un effet positif sur la
croissance j'étais plus simple à mettre
en oeuvre
la seule chose et après j'arrête rappelé
mme x et je pense que ce projet est dans
les cartons effectivement parce que oui
le prix
c'était déjà prévu à l'époque sous
valéry giscard d'estaing c'est un projet
d marque my oise et un projet d'espacé
pas un truc d'admis du parti et ça
continue et s'est portée et on voit bien
que le poids des ministres aujourd'hui
est assez faible et que malheureusement
les élus ne savent pas tenir la position
après tout représente la population et
donc quand on est alors on va dire oui
60% des gens disent que ça aura pas
d'impact
je pense que 60% des gens n'ont pas et
c'est sûr qu'il serait autre fac parce
qu'on a quand même fait le grand
brouillard
on nous a quand même fait quelque chose
qui était à la fois très anxiogène puis
ça va bien puis c'est anxiogène avant la
décision
et puis jusqu'à la fin d'année vous
parliez effectivement de série b pour
les crédits d'impôts non parce que moi
par exemple je me manque dans un ehpad
tous les mois je paye des sommes sont
différents ma référence et 2016 moment
était pas en un peu on n'est pas dans le
ton ne tient pas compte
et moi j'ai toujours pas compris à quel
moment j'aurais le crédit d'impôt
correspondant à 50% de la somme
plafonnée 7500 euros maximum par an
je ne sais pas mais parmi les 60 % à 63
cents soit sans le côté bientôt versier
merci beaucoup plus tôt non moi ce qui
me méthode un petit peu c'est que tout
le monde semble se réveiller enfin tous
les anti prélèvement à la source semble
se réveiller aujourd'hui je veux dire
c'est une décision qui a été prise sous
le gouvernement de hollande de françois
hollande et la personne n'a rien dit à
l'époque ne ba oui pourquoi pas puis là
tout d'un coup vous êtes tout cela vous
reviendra à baisser dans quatre mois
c'est scandaleux faut l'arrêter il
fallait vous réveillez vous il fallait
râler avant avant j'ai râlé avant
certes on a entendu personne en même
temps une personne n'a entendu aucun
partisan mais il n'y a plus que trois
pays amis aux majeurs trois pays qui ne
l'ont pas majorité n'entend pas tout en
raison des qualités comme les autres
puisque on a une fiscalité familiales et
par soyez donc séville en plus ça pose
un problème
mais l'aixois qui faisait loin tout à
fait ça ne semble être pas par nature la
mesure prise par les fonctionnaires de
bercy comparaison c'est trop tard je
suis d'accord c'est d'ailleurs la raison
parce que si il manuel macro ont eu un
doute quand même parce qu'il a peut-être
sens politique quand même mais qu'il n'a
pas rien rien pu faire c'est qu'une fois
que la mesure est annoncé que le train
est lancé on peut plus l'arrêter s'il
investit c'est la deuxième chose qui
m'inquiète parce que déjà en france le
le coût de récupération de l'impôt et
explose c'est ce qui coûte le plus cher
au monde sait les fonctionnaires
français pour vous le paierez la poule
est donc c'est des morts alors là on
peut se dire bah c'est des entreprises
qui vont faire le boulot
donc c'est vrai qu'on vous disiez très
justement il ya des comptables en plus
ça veut dire la eu un truc de trésorerie
que c'est donc logiquement devrait se
dire on va on va dégager des milliers de
fonctionnaires mais on peut parier se
retrouver ici dans un an il y aura il y
aura plus de fonctionnaires dans un an
qu'il y en a maintenant
alors qu'ils auront moins de boulot et
c'est donc ce sera chaque fois des
mesures qui ne servent à rien et au
point de vue réduction de 2 de l'emploi
il ya jamais il ya de plus en plus de
gens aux finances et pas de moins en
moins alors qu'ils ont de moins en moins
de choses à faire
ce qui aurait été bien c'est pour que
les entreprises puissent un peu un valet
à la pilule un peu mieux aurait été de
dire bon bah voilà vous aller collecter
l'impôt
si messieurs dames mais de l'autre côté
voilà les économique l'ont fait sauf que
ça c'est pas du tout pédagogique et
jamais disant voilà on va mais que voilà
on est c'est ce qu'on nous dit sinon
sans surprise et on allait jusqu'à
effectivement l'échangé tard et je crois
que le plan de baisses de réduction du
nombre de fonctionnaires c'est moins
1500 fonctionnaires de mon budget 2010 9
vient en fait moi personne parce que
moins 1500 vous remplacer les départs en
retraite et vous êtes en plus c'est
comme toujours mais oui quelque chose
qui naquit à kona tu peux avoir c'est
quand même ma spécialité du pays
français quand on a une problématique à
régler on passe toujours sur l'impôt je
sais pas si vous avez vu c'est un peu qu
est quand même cet été il ya eu une
polémique sur le taux de sel dans
l'alimentation et la solution française
pour lutter contre du sel dans
l'alimentation s'est il fait d'éditer
fiscale s'impose de se dire qu'on va
contre les choses d'en rajouter nice et
qui sait sur quoi les héros pour
novembre
pendant l'époque de 80 kilomètres à la
trêve afin peut aussi légitimement très
très inquiet quand on voit comme l'échec
patent du logiciel louvois pour paiement
payer notre isna nos soldats
ça fait dix ans que ça dure ça marche
toujours pas on attend un nouveau
logiciel qui est fait est conçu
j'imagine par les mêmes personnes et qui
a été adoubé par les mêmes
fonctionnaires donc ça va être un loup
voix 2 et le poste mme le pauvre
troufions qu'étant en attendant somalie
etc
je veux dire lui et sa femme devait
attendre leur seul nom quand même assez
longtemps donc mais ça va être la même
chose c'était la même chose sur le r ici
le trou les indépendances et ça c'est
une catastrophe totale donc comme ce
sont les mêmes gens qui font les mêmes
erreurs je sais pas pourquoi tout la
crise aurait été touché par la grâce et
pour que ça marcherait mieux donc je
veux on peut être très inquiet ce qui
était drôle si vous avez entendu
françois van horne au moment où il y
avait en été dans les tergiversations il
a dit mais moi en 2007 c'était près
enfin il y avait aucun doute discussions
entreprises avec les ou peut-être même
avec les abus c'est une question qui
revient souvent dans le prélèvement à la
source d'une inquiétude c'est une
actualité je vous rejoins sur ce qui a
été dit au début de cette discussion je
pense qu'au début de l'année ça va être
un frein à la consommation parce que les
gens prudents en amont sur mon compte en
banque à la fin du mois donc savoir que
de voir ce qui se passe et donc lorsque
pas vrai mais non mais comme le dit est
sceptique jeudi un - à la fin du mois
sur la ligne en bas sur la fiche de paye
donc psychologiquement on va peut-être
moins dépenser ou ne pas faire un
investissement qu'on avait besoin de
faire pour avoir un petit peu comment ça
se passe et puis pour les entreprises
oui c'est compliqué pour les grandes
entreprises c'est compliqué pour les
petites entreprises c'est très compliqué
info finalement pour les entreprises je
crois de moins 25 salariés létale
allez proposer de faire le travail à
leur place je sais pas comment donc on
va voir c'est une véritable bien surtout
pour les entreprises aussi donc un peu
devant quelque chose c'est vrai comment
ça va se passer effectivement je crois
que le la mensualisation était trop
simple
oui c'est trop ça après il ya aussi les
excuses du coup parti on peut pas
arrêter les choses etc
je rappelle que l'écotaxe ont investi
des millions d'euros sur les routes on a
on a déjà eu des gros mettez moi j'ai
juste puissant millions oui c'est une
puce et les a déboutés il me semble
qu'il est et qui sont contraints à
l'aéroport je ne sais plus où aussi
après qu'on a acheté des terrains qu'on
mettrait 40 50 sur ce sujet donc en
affaires les habituels ne peut jamais
arrêté chose c'est pas qu'on peut
toujours arrêter chose il faut juste
avoir le courage et la volonté politique
et je suis d'accord il faut là aussi
l'analyse est suffisamment son temps et
à l'époque de nicolas sarkozy je crois
on avait créé aussi quelque chose qui
était qu'on ne pouvait pas faire un
projet de loi sans avoir une étude
d'impact confirmée par une deuxième
décision
moi je vois jamais d'étude d'impact sur
auckland pour jour et qui sort il y en a
certainement mais je pense qu'ils sont
rangés dans un dossier pour dire qu'ils
ont été faits là aussi où l étude
d'impact ou l étude d'impact ça coûte
combien à quelqu'un c'est non l étude
d'impact on avait enfin il ya le
parisien qu'il s'agirait de détresse est
un geste n'était pas c'est pas très
rassurant pour lever tout va bien mais
le metal tout juste avoir vu deux fois
qui va bien et ça c'est une bonne
solution pour les tarbaises utile là le
problème du predator à la source on l'a
vu il ya peut-être est d'ailleurs eu un
conflit un peu larvée entre le président
et le premier ministre communiste et
voir philippe était très favorable au
prélèvement à la source
emmanuel macron semble en avoir un peu
plus de réticence ça fait partie de la
séquence un peu terrible pour le pouvoir
non pas se le dise peut aussi servir de
l'écran de fumée c'est à dire que là
tout le monde ne parle plus que d'eux du
prélèvement à la source est ce que ça va
se faire maintenant c'est que ça on sait
que ça se fait mais enfin ça fait 15
jours que ça dure et maintenant on ne
parle plus que de ça donc qu'est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres la ryder cup et
barriques même nous on parle de la
démission nicolas hulot il ya mieux
witsel et la serbe ana
ça y est il est remplacé mais ça c'est
quand même servi un peu d' écran de
fumée
moi je veux dire bah oui on aurait
beaucoup plus parlé de beaucoup de
choses si on n'avait pas eu ce secteur
zellers action critique c'est pas
important mais je dis que ça tombe bien
je te dirai ça donne une impression de
fragilité
pas forcément dit que le président est à
l'écouté qui dit batteur faut quand même
faire attention surveille non c'est
quand même bien de temps en temps parce
que ces gens soient de temps en temps
habité par le doute c'est plutôt
rassurant
vous n'êtes pas la pression quand même
que peu l'impression que le présent 20
perd un peu la main c'est la première
fois dans le quinquennat enfin oui y'a
quand même je suis né des interrogations
des doutes alors des doutes très fort de
l'opinion des mêmes parmi les gens qui
le soutiennent il ya des gens qui sans
qu'ils ont voit un petit peu ou qu'ils
soutiennent au pouvoir faure il ya quand
même non non mais franchement c'est pas
la pression pour pour moi c'est c'est un
truc positif pour m'accrocher ce moment
de doute après social sur le reste de
l'actualité qui est partie bon nicolas
hulot je veux dire il est arrivé ce
c'est peut-être un peu un 1er juin dès
2000 à 10 démissionne le 3 le 3 la diva
finalement j'ai missionnerai peut-être
le 12
enfin je veux dire il passait son temps
démissionner et quand ils passaient pas
son temps annoncé une démission il était
en week-end prolongé du vendredi au
lundi à saint lunaire dont sa soeur
propriété du riche mais c'est sûrement
très joli mais très honnêtement c'est
pas c'est pas une grande perte pour le
gouvernement au point de vue car
périodiquement sa validité pas je vais
n'ya que c'est éliminer le plus assidu
et jamais existé mais symboliquement
c'est important
oui c'est un beau 10 passes et enfin
tard pour beaucoup de gens visiblement
mais en tout cas un petit personnel non
pour moi c'est pas du tout important
je veux dire ce c'est pas une façon de
faire de la politique c'est comme son
départ orchestrée comme ça sans prévenir
personne dans une incorrection
absolument totale
je viens c'est un irrespect des
institutions et des des gens élus
démocratiquement que sont le premier qui
est le président de la république qui
contrevient même pas qu'on s'en va après
le départ hier je ne sais pas parce
qu'il ya eu des bruits selon lesquels il
aurait dit leurs édiles dimanche qui
partait et qu'on ne veut pas écouter ce
qu'ils auraient pu prévenir ensuite
ensuite après ça donne une image des
gens de la société civile cette séquence
de larmes hier pour la passation de
pouvoirs avec françois de rugy mais sait
on est au delà du lamentable
qu'est ce que c'est que ces gens ne faut
pas faire de politique si on n'a pas les
nerfs si on n'a pas tous allés pleurer
comme mais pourquoi est ce que nicolas
hulot se met à pleurer
on comprend pas là ces licenciements il
pleure sur son propre départ on est là
mais se dire s'est il faut qu'il fasse
du théâtre c'est un autre métier c'est
pas un homme politique il n'y avait rien
à faire dans un indice que la politique
de ben théâtre alors est ce que votre
mobile c'est une vraie la vraie question
des personnalités de la société civile
elle peut se poser mais il n'y a pas de
réponse nous sait bien que c'est pas
bien il ya là pour qui ça marche plutôt
bien
sous la mise et de la santé il ya des
milices pour qui ça marche plutôt bien
oui mais pour les liens des mines il
pour lesquelles ça marche plutôt mal
mais c'est mais voilà mais pour lui ça
n'a pas marché parce que parce que
quelqu'un qui est nicolas hulot c'est
une ancienne vedette de télévision dont
la majorité des gens qui sont coincés
peu faim l'opinion publique s'est
enthousiasmé pour lui je vous rappelle
qu'il ya quand même quelques années il y
avait des gens qui disent il faudrait
qu'il soit président de la république
mais je dirai quelle catastrophe
échappé enfin je veux dire parce
qu'après par un jeu de sondages etc
imaginez nicolas hulot face à marine le
pen on à nicolas hulot président de la
république moi je m'exile enfin ça
serait une catastrophe
je veux dire non visiblement l'échappée
donc voilà qu'est ce qui représente je
ne sais pas il représente lui voilà une
sensibilité à fleur de peau des
atermoiements des voix là je pense que
françois de rugy fera sûrement mieux le
boulot et que très honnêtement on ne
peut pas décréter comme ça du jour au
lendemain que tout va changer
je pense très honnêtement que macron et
son gouvernement sont probablement les
les mieux placés pour pour conduire une
transition écologique à mars
vous êtes raisonnable restez vous restez
à c'était fils hal gill a tweeté quelque
chose de but didier porte qui m'a amusé
qui disait en gros je crains que la
nomination de françois de rugy ne
produisent pas le tremblement de terre
énorme nécessaires à la transition
écologique et c'est quand même un peu
vrai quoi c'est pas saison qui se pose
c'est qu'est ce qu'on aurait pu lui
proposer pour qu'il laisse tomber le
perchoir compose toujours jeudi mais
c'est assez étonnant troisième de l'état
qui bon jeu troisième personnage de
l'état il ya quand même une cave
intervient ça va encore lui asséna
d'ailleurs non mise en scène non mais ça
pose de ces surprenants ça pose le
problème de deux justement de la place
des parlementaires parce que quitter la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale pour
donner un ministre ça veut dire que mini
c'est mieux comme que brison a semblé
alors qu'on a tendance à conséquent
d'abord le contrat que vu ça à durée
déterminée et alterne en général pas du
tout si lui permet à ce que françois de
rugy côté là était élu il s'en est mordu
les doigts très vite avait annoncé qu'il
serait président de l'assemblée
nationale deux autres contrats
c'est ce que disent on est mordu les dom
il l'avait annoncé
donc on peut bien imaginer que tout le
monde est là en train de faire le calcul
notamment alors il s'en va quand il
était donc finalement il quitte un petit
peu avant
et devient ministre d'état le troisième
personnage dans le rang protocolaire du
gouvernement pour un tour c'est
sincèrement qu'un président de
l'assemblée on en place je ne parle pas
d'un ancien président devienne ministre
c'est vrai que l'on soupçonne en plus
l'exécutif de vouloir rogner les
pouvoirs du législatif c'est
symboliquement un peu délicat oui c'est
à l'évidence un signe que pour beaucoup
de gens c'est plus important d'être
ministre et président de l'assemblée
nationale c'est vrai que c'était pas
vrai c'était pas vrai il ya dix ans ce
n'est pas vrai il ya 15 ans et même une
particularité que c'est que c'est le
ministère de l'écologie de la transition
etc et qui avait quand même pas beaucoup
de nous prendre ma place de ministre et
que compte tenu de son parcours il y
avait pas totalement idiot et même des
gens bernant comme il avait été hué lou
lewis cohn bendit y avait il y avait
même du bien à québec et il y avait des
gens qui étaient contre un pour le
prologue pour le président et pour le
premier à voter oui mais non et pour les
gens cités aussi mais en fait le fond du
sujet je comprends les gens si tu es je
peux le fond du cg c'est qu'on a
quelques ministères qui sont vraiment un
avion incontournable en ce gouvernement
et c'est certainement pas lui ça
l'écologie et je suis désolé c'est pas
non plus mystère des sports on voit bien
aidé en finistère là on nous prend
effectivement général quelque chose sur
la pelouse du marketing
fred efficacité parce qu'on se dit
effectivement un sportive à être mieux
que quiconque pour gérer les sports la
finale
ce que je vais dire est absolument
choquant mais sur les vingt dernières
années les meilleurs ministres espoir
qu'on a eu c'est marie george buffet
était quand même commune il a validé pas
sportif alors qu'on a vu passer quand
même des spécialistes du sport un bon
voilà et ça c'est toujours plus ou moins
mal terminé c'est la même chose bizarre
de jouer au bout du sujet c'est le
moment à quoi sert un mystère d'écologie
ça que je considère toujours que
l'écologie pour être dans toute décision
politique quelle qu'elle soit ce qu'il
faudrait pas que tu as aimé
ce ministère et il est le répartir dans
tous les ministères
la même façon que quand on prend une
décision on réfléchit à l'aspect
sécurité chsct dans les entreprises on
se dit je vais pas construire un bon
s'il doit s'écrouler par exemple un pur
par son ami t'a bien de la même chose on
doit se dire que je parlais d'un pacte
je prends une décision politique quel
est son impact écologique qu'est ce que
je ne dois pas faire pour être dans le
cas de la transition alors ça envoie
certains messages forts d'avoir mis sa
la transition mais quand on voit ce que
les mystères les ministres ont comme
moyens financiers comme écoute parce que
la situation avec travers et là une
particulière et je veux dire mais je
comprends la logique économique
simplement elle doit se passer au
détriment d'écologie mais l'écologie
doit être en toutes choses
j'ai même toujours pas compris pourquoi
y avait même des partis écologiques à
banias pas le parti de la vie oui il
faut pas tuer des gens y'a pas le parti
de l'amour bah oui faut aimer les gens
pour moi c'est une philosophie elle est
dans toute décision et devait alors que
ce soit le moyen pour certains
d'existence politique parce que derrière
tout ça ya toujours la volonté de la
carrière monsieur du rugby
l'écologiste un peu résumé je respecte
ça c'est son métier c'est un
professionnel pour très bien mais au
delà leur est si les dents tout aux
décisions à 51 divine quand on décide de
construire une faute à l'endroit
on regarde si on va écraser des insectes
abîmer la pelouse comme vale entretenir
la nettoyer dans quels cas de s'asseoir
c'est en avant la décision et cdh ont
toutes les formes de décision dans tous
nos marchés publics pendant très
longtemps c'était de la poudre aux yeux
pendant très longtemps c'est la poudre
aux yeux aujourd'hui on a des clauses
strictes sont appliquées sur la partie
cologie qu on nettoie pas un abri
voyageurs pour parler de ces jean claude
decaux en utilisant des produits qui
vont détériorer on est en eau pure en
dérangement ça fait partie de tous les
éléments c'est le résultat positif
effectivement cette pression l'axé prise
de conscience les lier à des années et
des années de pressions des partis
écologiques mais maintenant ça doit
faire partie de toutes nos décisions et
donc c'est pour ça je pense qu'on a des
ministres emblématiques ont fait du
marketing ont fait de la com
on a des gens qui peuplent font du
théâtre des gens qui n'ont pas de moyens
parce que bercy écrase d'écologie demain
matin pour aller dans votre sens tout à
fait raison mais les partis politiques
parti politique écologie n pepa qu'ils
sont
c'est très bien l'ambition individuelle
les parties de leurs avocats justement
dans le territoire comme ça quand acquis
qui est un territoire économique très
vision très un poids très important
la dimension écologique lll elle est
forte dans vos rapports avec les
entreprises avec les fortes les
présentent comme le dit laurent est
présent dans toutes les décisions et
même si nous n'avons pas un service ou
un département de l'écologie c'est tous
les services dans toutes leurs actions
au quotidien qui ont cette composante
évidemment je rappelle qu'on est sur un
territoire qu'il ya plus de 60% vert et
bleu donc on a un territoire qui n'est
pas bétonner l'écologie ça fait partie
oui ça fait partie du quotidien tout
simplement dans toutes les actions qui
sont menées
l'impact à court moyen long terme et
c'est un quotidien et on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir un monsieur ou madame écologie
dans nos infrastructures dans nos
institutions pour que ce soit totalement
une réalité dans tout ce qui est mis en
oeuvre par et l'économie pardon est-ce
que les bus qui vont emmener les
visiteurs et des spectateurs de la red
allegri sont électriques alors m'ont
tous les bus ne sont pas électrique
hélas après la ya aussi une réalité
technologique mais vous savez 50 ans
neil est un territoire aussi
d'innovations beaucoup de recherches qui
sont faites chez nous on travaille avec
les partenaires industriels du secteur
sur les véhicules du futur effectivement
tout ce qui est électrique est très
important et j'espère qu'à l'avenir et
peut-être pour les jo de 2024
on aura des moyens de transport beaucoup
plus écologiquement certains électrique
il ya aussi derrière une réalité
économique un parc de bus existants avec
ile-de-france mobilité on va tout
changer du jour en main soit il faut
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont par
contre oui c'est une volonté d'évolution
et on est dans cet axe là mais on l'a
dit au début d'ailleurs sûr
ryder cup on avait dans la candidature
fait énormément de travaux liés à la
mise aux normes et aux évolutions du
parcours de saint quentin pour aller
encore plus loin dans l'écologie sur le
site pilote depuis longtemps pour la
biodiversité reconnu par le muséum
d'histoire naturelle donc mais tout à
fait à la pointe dans ce domaine et vous
remercie je rappelle le 22 septembre la
compétition le l'open tv 78 signale
aussi en outre cette profit de la
recherche contre le sens ce sera à saint
nom la bretèche la veille le 21 c'est
c'est de l'association saint louis qui
soutient l'institut universitaire lequel
cinq buts voilà c'est bien aussi
merci infiniment à nos côtés merci
infiniment monsieur le président basauri
c'était ok merci le gouvernement
spd-verts cadets choqué et jean-charles
la jolie et à très vite pour nouveau
numéro de paf
[Musique]